a clean edit
um
so welcome to our session about
environmental art as activism with BT
wolf a wonderfully creative Artist as
you will soon see my name is Carson nem
I'm a business and technology writer
here in Berlin thank you so much for
coming out to the venue here this
wonderful auditorium at the Natural
History Museum Natural Science Museum
I'm sorry
PT unfortunately
cannot join us this morning here in
person we will hear from her in a moment
why that is the case the session is all
about her art her incredible boundless
creativity and how she kind of uses this
to make science and scientific insights
particularly into climate change and
sustainability more accessible to
everybody so BT originally from Britain
but now she lives in Los Angeles it's
fairly early in the morning good morning
BT how are you this morning
hey custom yeah I'm good and it's
wonderful to be here in this virtual
capacity
um you know as you mentioned I sadly
can't be there physically because I'm
really choosing to limit my flying at
the moment I'm given all the
environmental work and so I've become
pretty much like uh based in La as much
as possible
so I can hear my myself in the
background
um which I guess is
um Let me let me try one thing hang on
one side
so this is the beauty of modern
technology everybody has to tweak a
little bit
to make it work but it's still amazing
that we can see you
and that this is working that you're
able to join us this way and I
absolutely adore your studio I have to
say this with
and by the way what you're seeing in the
background already
um
shows you that pte is not just a digital
person even though she does incredible
work with
interactivity and Technology but she
also loves all things analog and haptic
and we'll talk about this
because you see all the actual vinyl
ncds in the background there
so
and I see and I see the mark for the
morning coffee I hope you at least got a
chance to enjoy this then let us know
please if this works for you
yeah I I think so let me just try
speaking of it that seems to be better
um I was I was just getting very
loud echo which made me feel like I was
stuck inside my head which you know I I
am in many ways so yeah that's a lot
better so um yeah sadly I am I'm beaming
in today because
um as I mentioned you know the the
environmental work which we're going to
be talking more about is such a big
Focus for me right now and it has been
really since I saw An Inconvenient Truth
as a teenager
um in the cinema and so just becoming
more conscious of flying because I feel
like it's all the little actions that we
take that we think maybe are
inconsequential that are actually what
it's about it's these micro decisions
that we're all gonna have to start being
more
um really conscious about so
um I wish I could be there because the
theater looks so beautiful and chatting
with you Karsten in person is always
such a pleasure and to be you know with
the audience but it's it's lovely to
have this option available to us
well again we're glad that
um
technology makes it possible to have you
here
um you of course tomorrow we we were
sort of here assembled talking a day
before cop 27 27 begins last year you
were at cop 26 uh in Glasgow presenting
um you're from green to RED project
before we show a little clip
um tell us please kind of in a nutshell
what this is about and what we're about
to see in that in that video
absolutely so in a nutshell
from green to Red is a environmental
protest art piece taking 800 000 years
of atmospheric CO2 data
and weaving it into this Dynamic
interactive timeline of the planet
depicting Rising CO2 levels and human
impact and it's set the visualization is
set to a song I wrote as a teenager
after seeing An Inconvenient Truth a
track called from green to Red which is
also now the name of the project and
I'll you know talk more about how that
all came to be but the intention behind
the piece was really to take data huge
amounts of data that often for people is
you know really hard to absorb and hard
to get a sense of and turn it into
something that everyone could see
everyone could relate to and uh you know
almost speeding up 800 000 years into
four minutes you know this four minute
song visualization so that we can see
where we are on the planet right now
very good then I would like to ask the
tech team to please um
show us that video then we all know
um what you just described we can see it
and afterwards we're going to talk a
little bit about how you actually turn
this into an interactive art piece
um in in London as well
[Music]
foreign
proud to see what we won't even say we
don't wanna know don't wanna know don't
wanna know don't wanna know
no we don't wanna know don't wanna know
don't wanna know don't wanna know
[Music]
and I'll walk you to school where you'll
learn how to live buy a new set of rules
[Music]
forgive us my dick can't you see is the
truth that we don't wanna know don't
wanna know don't wanna know don't wanna
know
thank you
[Music]
what happened to love is
so much here to say what happened to
love
[Music]
don't live like it's too late
murder is only defined by mankind but
the creatures don't know for what cause
they have died
[Music]
we sit at the top with our great peace
of mind we don't wanna know don't wanna
know don't wanna know don't wanna know
[Music]
no we don't wanna know don't wanna know
don't wanna know don't wanna know
so remember denial is a halt of the head
let your eyes and your heart get your
reason instead when the hungry I'll stop
the full are still fat we sit at the
crossroads the green turns to red but we
don't wanna know don't wanna know don't
wanna know don't wanna know
I know I don't wanna know don't wanna
know don't wanna know you don't wanna
know
[Music]
what happened to love is
too late what happened to love is
so much
don't live like it's too late
[Music]
there's so much here to save
beautiful thank you very much
um we all saw kind of this the green
fabric like structures Float by turning
into red obviously that gave the artwork
its name explain a little bit to us
please what we just saw I mean it's
obvious that this refers to
um the the carbon emissions and the CO2
concentration in the atmosphere but
um how did you visualize it you said
it's based on 800 000 years of of NASA
climate data
how did you create this kind of visual
sculpture out of it and and
um
what uh
well you know what is it supposed to
um to show
yeah Carson well so
um yeah what you saw was uh 800 000
years of NASA NOAA climate data looking
at the
um atmospheric CO2 levels and really
it's quite simple it's not
some
um incredibly clever code or in terms of
the visualization it's really like a
reimagined graph
um so it's sort of like taking an
existing graph and demonstrating it
showing it in a different fashion
um I worked you know with this special
effects company
lost our audio no
this woven timeline you know this kind
of planetary timeline where by as the
CO2 levels started to rise you know the
threads everything about the the fabric
the visualized fabric was getting
chaotic and the the colors were changing
the threads were getting pulled apart so
um it was really pretty simple in terms
of just putting in those data points and
that you know both in terms of the
planetary date and the
carbon PPM and then
really allowing the game engine to
generate something until it was like
visually what I could see in my mind
um I think the thing that's really
interesting which you guys don't get to
experience in this version is the
interactive installation which was at
the London design bien Ali
so that almost the main version of the
project is this interactive version
where you can move your hands over the
fabric as it's being woven in front of
you and you can pull out the specific
carbon PPM and the date and I feel that
really gives people a sense of being
able to interrogate
um you know those different points and
where things where we start to really
screw things up in a way and it cop 26
you know because cop27 is now happening
I was actually meant to be there as well
um but I I felt well along with the
decision to really limit flying I also
felt that this one was much more
administrative last year was it felt as
if all the well eyes of the world for
the first time in a way were on cop
um in a way that they hadn't been in the
previous years and it like that was
really the potential for positive action
to follow the conference and I was doing
a installation of the project at the New
York Times climate Hub a projection onto
the conference center you know which was
this 500 for uh 550 feet across
structure and you know a number of other
things and yeah it really felt as if
like oh my God maybe
maybe this is it maybe this is the time
we're gonna wake up and start actually
doing something and so I won't comment
on where I feel we are with that today
but um yeah it was definitely wonderful
to see the project
um part of that conference in in such a
big way
so you mentioned on another occasion you
mentioned that
um you wrote the song you told us when
you were 16 but you also said um you
never expected to actually have to
perform it in some way because after
algor's documentary
um people would wake up and do something
why why do you think so little has
happened you mentioned also that all of
us have our own part to play obviously
it makes a difference whether we're
driving four billion uh you know
combustion engine cars or more cleaner
cars for example or how we heat Etc so
why why do you think we as humans are
showing such a laid back attitude to a
more and more pressing
project problem
foreign
I
feel like
technology ironically because as in I I
say it
so now ironically we have lost thanks to
technology our feed our sound feed I
don't know a magic feeling or a
different dimension or a new way of
seeing or experiencing can you hear me
sorry for interrupting you because we
lost the audio feed here in the in the
auditorium for a moment exactly when you
said ironically technology okay
tell us again please thank you okay
so
um
firstly yeah big question and I would
say that for me you know technology has
in addition to doing many wonderful
things for us as human beings and the
reason I said ironically is because I'm
criticizing technology when I also do
utilize it in a lot of the projects to
create these new ways of experiencing
seeing music and art and kind of opening
up these other worlds
but I feel like technology has
fast-tracked what a lot a lot of what it
means to be a human being on this planet
without reflecting the costs in the fast
tracking process process
and shortchanging us in many ways so
suddenly we have all this access but we
don't really have any value we have all
this noise but we don't have curation
and I think our relationship human
beings relationship with the natural
world and with art in terms of really
what art does to us on a core
fundamental human being level I think
technology has disrupted those two core
relationships
so I feel a lot of it is because as
we've innovated we haven't factored in
the costs
okay and there's
an audio Hall once again sorry about
that we live now I'm talking about the
um you know privileged part of the world
but we live in a way that is just you
know honestly not sustainable and hasn't
been for a very long time
so um we have unfortunately some some
audio issues
um but
[Music]
it's
so it's the internet I hear we can see
you but we can't always hear you
unfortunately I don't know how that can
be explained
um maybe it's the the zoom Engineers
that could tell us
um
but
do you you said that technology kind of
has
made us lose touch with certain things
with nature with with the haptic world
you of course you've tried with many of
your projects to bring them together
explain please
a couple of things that you've done I
don't want to do it I'd rather you do it
and so tell us please how you try to to
bridge the analog in the digital
okay and hopefully the audio is of
course working now
yeah I'm gonna speak I'll speak slowly
this is making everyone slow down
um and just in case the sentiment didn't
come across in what I was saying before
I think the issue is that technology
fast-tracked a lot of things but didn't
reflect the costs in that fast tracking
process so that's really why we don't
have a sense of um
the costs of you know us having whatever
we want whenever we want talking
there we go
sorry BD so in terms of your other
question the the thing I'm interested in
is how you take the best of the old
world and the best of the new world
and you find that bridge between the
physical and the digital
where you know you're still bringing in
the ceremony the tangibility the
storytelling that we had in the say
physical music listening world but also
not just music every medium you know
journalism art
poetry literature
um you know all of these new digital
forms I think have lost something in a
lot of ways so I like to think about how
you can
create these deeper tangible ceremonial
moments around music art and these other
worlds in the digital space
um and so two examples of those
one was a anti-stream from the quietest
room on Earth so it was the actually the
world's first Live 360 AR stream
so very technological but it was all set
up via a record player a physical record
player that was playing
in the original anechoic chamber the
space where Helen Keller experienced
silence for the first time
as this anti-stream in the streaming age
so you had the album playing on repeat
physically 24 hours for a week and you
know as you were listening in this
beautiful ceremonial space
where they discovered Rogue frequencies
and psychoacoustics this really amazing
audio room where also you can hear the
blood rushing through your veins it's
it's this very eerie experience
um the lyrics and the artwork would be
streaming out of the vinyl and
surrounding you in this chamber and
taking you into the visual landscape of
each song as it was playing in real time
as this sort of Fantasia experience for
the album in the digital age and really
to me that was the equivalent of being
seven years old
um as a you know as a kid and opening up
Abby Road and feeling like Abby Road
just came to life or whatever the record
was it came to life around me
um so that was really a an embodiment of
me trying to
create a version of that but for where
we are today
you said you had another second project
or you
that you wanted to describe yeah there
are
for sure
um yeah there are there are many
projects
um but I'd say the the second one which
you mentioned
haptic you mentioned tangible
and that it also has a nice very nice
story in terms of
it was a reimagining of the album jacket
thinking about the album jacket
originally as this art form which we
lost as well really when we moved from
physical to digital and I wanted to
think about that different way but it
happened very organic
Zoom silenced you again I'm afraid
and Yoko and Ringo and Hendrix all of
these amazing musicians had lived with
the tailor who dressed a lot of those
musicians a tailor called Mr Fish and
um
I I I am I still with you no now you're
back you were you were unfortunately the
sound dropped for a moment but you were
I'll briefly explain this for the
audience here you were talking was about
talking to us about this jacket that you
made that basically had some chips
inside so that people could with an NFC
chip or or a reader could kind of or
their smartphones could play the song
embedded in the actual fabric of the
actual jacket so how on Earth um How
does a
a musician
I could see many musicians come up with
this idea probably
um but how do you how do you turn that
into a reality do you have you always
had a proclivity uh to technology even
as a child and then
you're maybe a little engineer inside as
well as an artist
yeah I think so I mean
um for me I never saw all of these all
of the fields and the disciplines as
being
really disconnected from one another I
think I felt like
whatever your creativity or wherever
your imagination creativity curiosity
took you that was what you should follow
and growing up you know I definitely had
as much of a love in a way for Ecology
and philosophy and you know all these
other fields as I did music and art and
I never wanted to limit you know myself
to just being in one lane or one Avenue
with the musical jacket you mentioned
yeah you could tap your phone onto the
fabric to hear the music that was woven
into it
but for me the really cool thing was
more the concept you know it was um cut
by this tailor who dressed Bowie Hendrix
Jagger out of this fabric which actually
had the the waveforms kind of woven into
the fabric so you could see the music
you could literally see the music that
was woven into it and the music was
recorded in the room where McCartney
wrote Eleanor Rigby where Hendricks
wrote The Wind Cries Mary all these
songs had been written and so I love
this idea of capturing the resonance and
the history of this space this amazing
space and translating that into
something that you could visualize and
you could see and it was also really a
celebration of the album jacket of you
know the vinyl days that we had kind of
lost
um and so for me that was the the story
of it was the part that really
you know really I loved and then the the
technology part was like a little twist
you know
very good you do you have one other
standout project that I think we should
take a quick look at which is raw space
um and maybe you could briefly tell us
what we're going to see in the next
video
um and then we can talk about it before
we We Roll It
cool
so I mentioned this anti-stream from the
quietest room on Earth and that was with
Bella
okay Zoom is dropping out on you
unfortunately it is stopping you the
sound and with Robert rauschenberg and
John Cage and Andy Warhol all these
amazing artists doing experiments with
engineers
so I was rebooting this historic program
50 years on with that anti-stream
experience
and this was the second chapter to that
story
um so this was where me and Nobel Laura
Laureate Robert Wilson who discovered
Cosmic microwave radiation
using the Honda horn antenna he and I
did a space broadcast of the record
through this historic antenna
very good and then I'd like to ask the
team to please show us that second video
of raw space
the place a Hilltop in New Jersey the
setting giant antennas like monstrous
eyes and ears straining
watching waiting
and now 50 is on this historic horn will
be used for the first time to Beam music
into space my latest record raw space
should do it together
one
[Music]
so here we are we're in front of the
home Dill horn antenna which was used to
prove the validity of The Big Bang
Theory
one the scientists of Nobel Prize
what's so exciting about raw space is
not only will we be creating the first
fully augmented reality 360 album stream
but will also be the first to beam an
album into space via this horn antenna
today they are looking as all Humanity
looks to the vast potentials of outer
space
but first I was perplexed how to do
something like this but as I thought
about it I started having ideas
we all know radio
if we could modulate the sound on a
microwave carrier it could go through
the horn and go up into space
so what do we have here it's a fancy
radio that shows what we're transmitting
and if you look at the screen there's
this big spike that's the radio signal
that's carrying your Musical
oh we can listen here we are
and so when we turn the antenna up that
signal will be the one cutting up into
space okay well should we do that now
yes yes
but you know it's amazing how when
things are made well they last
Just Like Music folks
so this is the end of the horn
where we can connect to either a signal
Source or a receiver
right now we have a radiator in there
that can radiate microwaves and a
speaker we can broadcast sound
it comes out of this horn
up to the surface up there
which is a piece of paraboloid sort of
like a little piece of the reflector of
your flashlight or something then it
makes it into a signal is going pretty
much in One Direction into space
well maybe if this if this or it will go
past the planet Venus on its way out of
the solar system I love creating worlds
for each of my albums and sending this
one into space makes it truly Universal
well I guess it's time to start the
broadcast okay should we do it together
one two three
hello this is BT wolf and this is the
raw space
coming to you from the rawest recording
space on the planet and transmitting
into the rawest space out
wonderful yes please
Club
so
clearly I'm not the only fan of this
your music is traveling further and
further into space now and has been
since that project was launched do you
have any idea how far your songs have
traveled yet
the last time I checked which was like
three years ago
um the music apparently according to one
of the engineers was halfway on its way
to
um
I think it was a Proxima Centauri so
that was yeah that was the last update I
had
this is sort of a bit of a speculative
question I guess do you do are you
convinced that there are other
beings out there that
May one day
be able to hear the music enjoy the
music
yeah interesting
um carsten I mean I look I feel like
human being knowledge is so basic
compared to even nature you know
Nature's technology and intelligence and
creativity is way greater than our own
so for us to be the only beings floating
around in space I I I I I think that's
doubtful
um a number of friends and astronomers
and you know some of the people I've
worked with would send articles there
have been more and more articles saying
oh strange signal received from you know
unknown source and
way out there and
um so and we sent that as a radio signal
so we actually sent the music as a radio
signal so that it could get past the
Earth's atmosphere and get all the way
out there
um and it was it was wonderful it
doesn't show it in the video but the
first time I met Robert Wilson
we were in front of that horn antenna
and I said you've used this instrument
to receive but have you ever used it to
transmit
and he's like no you know also because
once you've won a Nobel Prize for a
discovery
um with this instrument you know you
it's almost like you've checked that box
so I said well I have this record called
raw space and it was called raw space
based on this anechoic chamber nothing
to do with space but in theory could we
do this you know broadcast could we send
it out into space and he said no because
the music will get to a point in the
Earth's atmosphere and then stop and I
thought that was the end of the
conversation and a month later I get an
email from him saying you know BT I
figured it out I can do an update on the
horn antenna and we can do this
broadcast and this is a National
Historic Landmark this is a serious
instrument so the whole thing was
amazing and magical and and
yeah
let's hope for the best
because I I discovered that that horn
antenna had been first used by JPL NASA
to send a phone call via space which was
being bounced off a mylar balloon
and received at Bell Labs at the horn
antenna and so I ended up then giving a
talk at NASA's JPL about my work and
showing this video and that was after
that talk one of the chief Engineers
comes up and shows me these atmospheric
CO2 graphs and that was how from green
to Red came to be you know
so we had a bit of an audio issue again
but basically these two projects are
connected raw space because of your
presentation at JPL led to from green to
red
yes correct
okay very good you are involved in
another very intriguing to me intriguing
project which is kind of a
musical you called it seed bank in
Norway in spitzbergen
and tell us a little bit please about
what's behind that what the idea behind
it is because I think that's yet again
connected to a basic idea of from green
to red
yes and I not knowing what you're here
you know it's almost like a haiku
or it's like a new way of communicating
what actually comes through
um so this year I was asked to be part
of the First music
seed bank essentially and the idea is
like the seed bank to take music that is
culturally significant and preserve it
for the long term so that in the worst
case scenario which it looks like human
beings may be headed towards we
potentially have you know like a time
capsule or a way of restoring
um music and culture to the planet as
well as you know the the vegetation and
the plantation
so my music along with the international
library of African music
um music and work from the a polar music
prize and a number of other big
um culturally significant
collections was encoded in glass by
Microsoft research to be preserved in
this vault in svalbard for 10 000 years
and this is the first time that data has
been stored in glass in this way that is
it's hugely exciting because you can
store vast amount of data cold you know
in terms of not using any energy until
you need it in this very durable way
which is storing it in glass and so even
that alone opens up huge questions
around you know energy and storage
capacities and taking a lot of things
off servers
um so yeah it's a really exciting
project it's called the global music
vault
um a geek question namely how
um you know let's hope that the worst
doesn't happen we simply want to access
the data even a hundred years from now
how do we do this because if I if I take
an example from my University years
which are a couple of decades back more
than a couple uh
my Master's thesis is stored on a floppy
disk and of course these days there's no
computer that can out of the box acts as
a floppy disk anymore what's the idea
behind this how do you how do you get to
that data
if you ever want to again
so I lost you Karsten the second part of
that question but I got the first bit
which is how do we access it in the
future
um it's actually via a microscope you
use you'd use a microscope
okay let's hope that
um that's clear to everybody who wants
to access it 100 years from now or a
thousand years from now
um
you this this theme of sustainability is
a recurring one in your work tell us a
little bit please you already mentioned
that as a child growing up you felt
connected to Nature where does that come
from
thank you
I think we're all connected with nature
I think it's something we innately have
as human beings
and it's almost that we disconnect
ourselves from nature
um you know because of the human ego
because of material you know all the
things that we think we need or that
Society teaches us that are important
and I feel like the natural world is
um it's
you know it's our greatest teacher it's
our greatest inspiration it's where the
best art and creativity and as I said
technology you know we think that we can
invent all this incredible technology
just look at Nature's regenerative
Powers when we let Mother Nature
regenerate it's incredible so I feel
like we all have it I think I yeah I
definitely had it I definitely felt it
from when I was
so whether it was a bug or you know any
kind of insect really I just uh I would
try and protect all the insects you know
I take snap snails to school in my
pocket
it was pretty pretty obsessed with
I guess all creatures great and small
and you know I've always been vegan and
things like that so
um yeah I guess I feel like
that very anthropomorphic view of
the planet and the hierarchy I think
human beings are actually
much more basic than we think and I
think there's an intelligence in the
natural world both in the animal kingdom
but also the plant and the fungi Kingdom
that we're only just beginning to wake
up to
so I guess the The crucial question
would be
you may have felt this natural closeness
to all the things that you describe but
how do we get people who do not feel
like that to relate to Nature more and
maybe move towards a circular economy
find an interest in these things
Etc any how can art help that what are
how can art make a difference
it's interesting you ask that because
I've been working on this Eco
documentary looking at these initiatives
is environmental circular economy
initiatives that are hidden in plain
sight in a way in California
one is with Noah who are re-wilding the
Abalone population of the West Coast but
in the last 10 or 15 years has gone down
to 10 of what it was
and the other one is this Urban wood
project rethinking the cityscape and
really planting the right trees in the
right environments which then at the end
of life cycle that would instead of
being mulch or Tinder where all the
carbon is released back into the
atmosphere
is it's becoming a guitar and so the
carbon is being stored in those
guitars buildings
whatever you know it whatever we're
making
and the
the central point of these um
documentaries is the guitar it's the
guitar that I play on because
it's the materials that the guitar is
made out of that point to these various
initiatives
and I think we have like a very short
teaser video of part of this
we do before we play that
um I'm curious as one of the guitars
behind you the one that you talked about
made out of this kind of wood
yeah does it does it sound any different
to you or or is it just like a regular
guitar but you know it it sort of does
something good for the planet as well
so it's made by Taylor guitars Taylor
Guitars I've been doing a lot of work
with
um because of their sustainability
focus and because they are very
instrumental using a music pun in
creating these new circular economies
and turning what was previously waste
materials into something of that
say that there's a big difference
between that type of wood and Rosewood
or mahogany
but I think that sounds as good as any
other word and you know this is also
where I think human beings have to
adjust we have to go with what's the
sustainable option not what our
preference is
um thank you for that
um then I would like to watch with you
that that third video which is actually
about
um the the kelp forests that you
mentioned which is a kind of algae if we
can play video number three please
so we're here at the cultured Abalone
Farm in Kalisa what we have in front of
us right here a lot of red Abalone which
typically then gets sold at Market but
there's also this amazing initiative to
rewild and replant and regrow a lot of
the white Abalone from babies and then
you know plant them off the coast of
California as part of this NOAA
initiative to really restore that
population that became obviously a
hugely decimated with the loss of the
seek help forest and the warming Waters
and other contributing factors so yeah
this place is pretty amazing because
obviously it's both operating on a sort
of commercial level but also as this
restoration facility for this greater
ecological initiative the thing I find
fascinating is just how this species
that is you know very iconic for
Californians so actually people really
do notice when it's no longer in the
oceans is really indicative of just so
many species that we're losing or in
danger of losing that we just don't
notice because it's sort of hidden in
plain sight and the Abalone is not
hidden in plain sight and so the fact
that we're noticing that you know makes
us think well what are we not noticing
so it's a great architect of the sea
kelp forest it's kind of like the otter
in that respect and it really is a sign
of the ocean's Health overall and health
of those habitats so
not just a snail
my name is Mona Olivas Tucker and I'm
the tribal chair for yakti chutija
yaktahini Northern chimash tribe of San
Luis Obispo County and region and our
membership is comprised of people whose
ancestry dates back to this one one area
for well over 12 000 years that's been
our homeland it's our ancestral
homelands it's part of who we are and
it's in our DNA
Not only was it a loss of a traditional
food source for tribal people it was a
loss of a food source for a lot of
people
but if the ocean's not healthy neither
are we
so you know take care of the things
around you it's the same thing as taking
care of yourself
so even if it doesn't appear to impact
you directly it does impact you directly
and if you want to survive and you want
to be healthy and you want your family
to be healthy and your kids grandkids
great grandkids otherwise what are you
doing are you just Burning Down The
House you know the quote an old song is
and what do you have then for your
children to live in nothing you know
just Rubble we want to do better than
that
I mean we all do this isn't an argument
really I mean this is this is just a
statement we all should want the same
thing
are you planning to do more are you
planning to produce more of these um
sort of little Clips or is it you said
documentary is it part of a larger
documentary what's the next step with
that
unfortunately we can't hear you right
now
to tell these stories it may not have
been as obvious what the connection is
with Abalone but actually the abalone
shell would typically be used for guitar
inlays so like this
would all be
um abalone shell
so that's the connection
with this initiative that's you know how
those two connect and
um yeah a bigger documentary is being
made at the moment which is looking at
you know everything from the sea to the
trees that we're planting
um
is is all of the you just showed us
unfortunately again we had a bit of an
audio problem but you just showed us
showed us how even the Abalone it kind
of ties in just like the recycled wood
does with your work with with the guitar
um is that kind of the Common Thread of
what you're planning
yes yes so the guitar is the vehicle to
tell these stories like the materials
that the guitar is made out of
are where we go and look at these these
Eco circular economy initiatives
you have one uh very recent project in
terms of circular economy which I found
intriguing as well along with Michael
Skype the singer of REM
you produce the very special kind of not
quite vinyl record
yeah so it was the world's first
bioplastic so non-pvc record that has
been commercially released and it was me
and Michael Stipe
um doing new music uh in Aid of Brian
Eno's environmental Charities so all of
the proceeds went to Brian Eno's charity
Earth percent
and yeah it's it was an amazing
um
there was an amazing response to it it
really opens up like the data storage
you know like this uh this new way of
storing huge amounts of data
This bioplastic Record also opens up the
door for how we can start doing things
without the costs we've made to the
planet that previously just kind of went
unnoticed really you know
it brings up the question of course if
it's biodegradable how many times can I
play it before it disintegrates it's it
almost feels like the opposite of the
spitzbergen project which is for
eternity and this shows us the fragility
sorry
absolutely but I'd say also with regular
vinyl
you can only play it so many times
before it also sounds impaired you know
so in a way this behaves exactly like
typical vinyl but it's just all you know
sugars starches like the material is you
know all bioplastic as I mentioned and
also the methods of production are you
know very different in terms of energy
usage and materials being used and
things like that
since you are
always at the Vanguard of Technology let
me pick your brain about two big trends
in
technology and and they're intersecting
with art one is of course
um artificial intelligence do you think
that artificial intelligence we see it
now producing uh pieces of art music
they can play like Beethoven for example
compose like Beethoven supposedly
um do you see artificial intelligence
technology as being able to
be actually creative
so I lost part of that question but I
get the sense of what you're asking
um
I think a version of AI in the creation
of Art
has always existed or has existed for a
long time in some capacity even going
back to top of the pops the early charts
you know things like that and then of
course yeah with the with algorithms and
then now with ai ai generated art
my feeling is that um
it's very good at imitating it's not
good at creating so it might be able to
imitate you know a work of Beethoven
almost perfectly but to actually come up
with the Ingenuity to form the original
creation and and that I feel is where AI
falls short and will always fall short
because it's about intention you know
human beings have an intention which
they bring to everything it's this
energy that governs the creation and if
you don't have intention which you know
um computers sadly don't then it's a
very different feeling it feels like
something that is surfacely on the
surface it's very beautiful
or it's quite you know convincing or
impressive but it doesn't have that
depth and that breadth to it and also
because it's the human imperfection it's
the things that we would never program
It's the weird voice of Leonard Cohen or
it's you know the the unused unusual
you know spacing of Matisse or whatever
it is it's these things that are
would be seemingly a mistake it's almost
in the mistakes
that's where art moves Us in those you
know mistakes in those imperfect human
being moments
so I feel that AI should be used for
things that human beings aren't good at
and there's a lot of stuff we're not
good at but the creation of Art
is something we're very good at
before I come to the other Tech Trend
this brings up the question of how you
work personally how do you iterate how
do you sort of find your own voice in
your music but also with your projects
how many attempts does it take for
example for a typical project I assume
you don't immediately know exactly what
the turnout will be
what do you mean by turnout sorry but
but the result will be I should have
said
okay
um
it goes back to something esoteric
you know which are and nature point to
all the time this mystery this big
mystery
and
I think the best are you know very much
conjures up that feeling of
something you can't put into words
something spiritual something that takes
you to another dimension
and for me that's where the ideas come
from
it never feels like excuse me
it never feels like my idea
and that's very much you know my
experience of it where
um it's almost like you see it in your
mind's eye you have a vision for
something and then you just have to
facilitate that vision
and you are really just the custodian of
the idea it's not there's no ownership
or ego about it but you just have to
keep the project on track for it to be
realized
the way it's meant to be realized
and and then you just let it off in the
world and see what it does that's how I
feel
very good the um ownership is an
interesting uh word here because that of
course is the other Trend that I'm that
I want to ask you about is nfts
can have you experimented with this this
for for people who are not so into Tech
is of course the the big Trend
um where artists sell kind of digital
certificates
um that are on the blockchain and
supposedly also live forever they can be
traded they can they cost money they can
supposedly make a lot more money in the
future it's kind of almost like a
speculative speculative art object
um what is your position on nfts and can
people maybe buy some BT music BT wolf
music as an nft
hell no
no no no no no no no no no no
interest
zero zero interest but but
um
it's actually
because
I feel like I talked about
my view of what's interesting in my
opinion is figuring out what the best of
the physical old let's call it the old
world and the best of the new world is
and how you can take the best of the old
the best of the new create something
totally different but that has these
elements you know it has the tangible
the ceremonial the story of the physical
world but it has the magic and the
immediacy and the excitement of the
digital world
and to me nfts are taking the worst of
the old world and the worst of the new
world
so for me that's something I have no
interest in
um because you're it's not tangible it's
not ceremonial there's no story to it
and you're using you know the the
digital aspect
um in the way that to me is the most
dull and superficial and
uninspiring
so to have that alone is one factor but
then to consider the energy usage the
fact that these you know disused power
plants are opening reopening because of
cryptocurrency
yeah I mean if there was a really good
reason to do it and there was an energy
cost
then maybe but for me there's no good
reason to be doing it in the first place
there's no why there's no intention and
if you ask most people why you know
they're excited about nfts or potentials
of cryptocurrency it's all the
speculative potential it's not anything
that is currently working and you know I
think that
a news item recently people have now
seen through it you know
thank you I almost hear there's a rhythm
to the audio glitches because it it
kinked out at the end on us again
unfortunately but I think your main
message came across before
um we sort of uh go to the Finish Line
with looking at your next project if
anybody here has a question please just
grade your hand we have a microphone
um and and we'll be happy to bring you
in
um
so
let me ask you uh are you are you
planning is your next project is it
going to be tied in with sustainability
again what are you planning next
so the next project is
essentially
um
a way of taking people inside the
artist's brain
so to me it's really interesting
that we all have like these multiple
streams going on in our brain all the
time you know there's
probably a music stream and a philosophy
stream and a memory stream and a visual
stream I mean yes there's there are
literally the different parts of the
brain and what they do what they
function as but also we have I feel like
this radio in our heads
all the time that's going between these
different channels
and so the next installation will be at
the London design biennale
next year 20
to hear all these different streams and
channels and Consciousness
um and the way people will be able to do
that is via this thinking cap which will
have the different audio channels
encoded in the in the capacity I
mentioned with micro Microsoft research
in this fashion that's very long-term
durable energy efficient so it will both
be sustainable and also a bit like the
musical jacket like creating a hat
version of the musical jacket
for those who can't be in London next
year
and be in this musical sculpture so to
speak experience it by themselves
um describe a little bit please what is
it you said it's like going into the
musician's head how many voices are
there right now what are they saying one
voice seems to be saying why not is
behind anything I do
most people ask why it's you say why not
well Carson
I say I think the two you've got to have
why and you've got to have why not
simultaneously
so you've got to understand why you're
doing something I'd almost say the why
is the most important that is the core
intention
but then you also have to have
well why not why wouldn't I do this you
know why wouldn't I send my music into
space or you know create an album as a
deck of cards or like whatever it is so
I think it's the paradox
and almost also talking about
sorry about that
you know we really can have that Paradox
existing in our work and we know that
the truth is actually within the paradox
so it's not one thing or the other it's
the tension between those two things
sorry for interrupting you but
unfortunately the the zoom tension got
in between you and us when you were
explaining the Paradox if you could just
recap that briefly first please thank
you
yeah so I I was just saying that it's as
much the why as it is the why not and
for me Y is the most important but why
not also has to be there as well and
when we are smart when we're intelligent
as human beings
um I think one of the good examples of
that is that we can hold these paradoxes
alive in our work in our understanding
in what we do and it's not that it's one
or the other it's the tension between
those two things that's where the truth
is that's where the magic is well now
you're basically going into quantum
mechanics
um and which makes me wonder are there
any technologies that you see on the
horizon that you would like to
experiment with like for example a
quantum computer
what would you do with a quantum
computer I you know the tech
the
um
the technology is always the last part
of the puzzle in a way for me in the
sense I never think oh I have to now do
something with ar or
NFC not nft uh
vision and technology is often a
component that can help open that up or
facilitate that but I never lead with
the technology it never starts with the
technology that is almost the last
like magic dust or something
that's nicely explained even though once
again Zoom wanted to turn us into lip
readers
um I'm afraid
um so if if I don't see any I wish I
wish I knew Braille I I apologize there
is one question from the audience so
please if we can get a microphone to the
gentleman please then I have one more to
wrap it up unless we have more questions
PT my name is organelle I've
participated in about 20 initiatives
several about sustainable development
goals and I'm afraid only two are still
going on all others get eyes are stuck
in the system over it Tuesday Ambitions
to Marginal and from those experience we
be identified one of the major
roadblocks and then you mentioned uh
to get streams in our into our heads
that sounded really interesting in that
respect because what we discovered is
that there are the laws of nature coming
from physics engineering mathematics
and we asked what do they apply in
management disciplines in social
sciences and also for this for the
sustainable development course and 50
percent of the respondents answered yes
and then came the big surprise a
scientists from the field of social
scientists said
yes we know they are important but we
don't know how to apply them in the
field of social scientists of social
sciences and other scientists aren't
answered there's no concept of what uh
uh a law of nature is and then the bells
weren't ringing and
experience a wait a moment when we look
into how decisions are made in
organizations in politics the big
decisions
they are verified for all sorts of
things methods
laws latest trends and so forth but
nobody is asking the question what laws
of nature May apply and at the end of
the day
there are countless decisions that
conflict with laws of nature like
Tipping Point laws of nature in
organizations and it appeared the higher
the value of proposition of an
Innovative solution is the quicker it
gets stuck it doesn't get through the
system anymore so I was wondering would
this be an idea for your project
to include something that gets the laws
of nature into the stream into our heads
in a particular into the heads of
decision maker and the experts in
management social sciences and so forth
I think that's a brilliant point and I
feel like that's a whole
that's a whole conversation you know a
recession like this one in and of itself
um and absolutely I mean even you saying
that thinking about the installation at
the London design biennale
if I can create a stream that helps
activate what exactly what you're
talking about you've
touching upon which is that we typically
have a lot of these fields even within
an organization you know different
departments are so siled from one
another they're not communicating there
are often very few Bridges you know
there are really still a lot of these
divides and through the work I do you
know yes I'm a musician but really
I feel like for me it's about making
Bridges the work is about making Bridges
between these areas of discipline or
understanding fields of of science
um that are typically not communicating
with one another and often the
scientists don't have the ways of
communicating that really allow people
to be drawn in you know as in they might
have all the knowledge and all the the
sort of expert information but they
won't always know how to communicate
that in a fashion that really
makes people think oh God yeah okay I
get it and so that's where art is a
wonderful
almost like this mercurial
um you know connector between these
different areas that often aren't in
dialogue with one another
well actually that's the second stream
when you talk what you talk about that
we identified as well there's another
one we could talk about
another time
with actually three streams that maybe
of
enormous value
so um yeah thank you for that yeah thank
you but maybe maybe you guys can follow
up I believe contact info is on your on
your website bdwolf.com correct then um
if you would like to follow up
please feel free to reach out you almost
answered my last question the last
question that I had which is sort of
what
what you hope to achieve with your own
work clearly clearly you're not just
making music out of a personal drive and
need but you um also want to achieve
something for the greater good at least
that's my feeling
um then explain a little bit please just
to wrap it up where where you hope to go
and maybe where the overarching
um kind of goal of all of this is
I think we all as human beings
have much greater power than we realize
and
for me
since I was very small
I was always thinking about what I would
leave behind I was thinking about my
funeral and the song I would have at my
funeral
and all these like morbid things that a
five-year-old is thinking about
but really what that was about was I
didn't care
how in a way
how this life went in terms of oh
the stuff I do in the world will people
like it you know will they like me
I didn't really care about that I just
wanted to make a contribution I wanted
to do something I felt had maybe some
value or could help or could leave
something and
I think we we all have that
um but I think that for a number of
reasons you know technology I spoke at
the beginning about it fast tracking
yeah at a time where instant
gratification you know we want instant
feedback instant gratification rather
than thinking a hundred
five hundred a thousand years you know
into the future
and really realizing that we're a part
of something much bigger
you know we are the largest ecosystem we
cannot take ourselves apart from the
greater whole and be okay
so I feel like my work is really
hopefully reminding people of the value
of Art and nature for our Humanity at
this point in time when that might seem
obvious
but I think we've forgotten
that art is so much more than
entertainment it is medicine in a lot of
cases for us to keep us vital and Alive
inside
nature literally sustains and
allows us to thrive not just survive and
so yeah that's what the work is about
reminding people of maybe aspects of
life that we might have forgotten about
because technology has made us feel very
good at innovating
but I think we need to reclaim as much
as we need to innovate going forward
that was a wonderful way to end the
session thank you so much for joining us
apologies um to both the audience here
and and to you for some audio glitches
that we had unfortunately recurring
audio glitches
um for me it was hugely rewarding anyway
I hope um our audience sees it the same
way thank you very much for joining us
thanks to ubd all the best can't wait to
hear and see your what what you're
dreaming up next thank you
it was wonderful to be here
thank you Carson
thank you very much
enjoy the rest of Berlin science week
and let's go to ciao